yeah thanks a lot Matus for for
organizing this whole thing and for
inviting me so today I'm going to be
talking about some fairly recent work
with some collaborators at Berkeley bond
quad Jew and Gentile Joe this is on some
ideas on how we can do better robust
estimation especially in high
dimensional settings so just to start
with some motivation may be generally
we'd like to design estimators and
learning algorithms that are robust to
to corruptions in the data that we might
have at training time but there's many
different types of corruptions that you
might care about
for instance if we're doing linear
regression one type of error we might be
worried about is what I call process
error which is where somehow the Y
coordinates are wrong and we want to not
necessarily assume that this noise is
zero mean but there might be some sort
of systematic correlation between this
error and the actual input another would
be measurement error where maybe Y is
measured correctly but we have some
systematic errors in how we actually
measured our inputs and another type of
error might just be outliers where some
small fraction of the data is just
completely wrong and while this is a
fairly old problem there's recently been
examples where in high dimensions a lot
of natural algorithms that you might try
actually don't work so to give it a
simple example let's suppose we just
wanted to ask to meet the mean of some
data set and there was some small
epsilon fraction of outliers and we want
an estimator that's fairly robust to the
presence of these outliers so in one
dimension where we're sort of all used
to this so the you know what sort of the
problem the problem is if these outliers
are really far away from the real data
then this can sort of skew the empirical
mean far away from the true mean and so
we'll use something more robust like the
median or the trimmed mean and the
problem is this
intuition doesn't generalize well to
higher dimensions so maybe like the
higher dimensional analog would be you
know take find like the empirical mean
of your data throw away everything
that's sort of far away and then take
the mean of the remaining points and and
maybe this seems like a good idea but as
the dimension gets large this actually
fails almost completely so here's an
illustration of why I suppose that the
clean data is just a Gaussian with will
even state has identity covariance but
it has some unknown mean and we want to
robustly estimate the mean of this
Gaussian in the presence of outliers the
basic issue is that in high dimensions
all of the points are going to be quite
far away from the mean so just what sort
of the LT distance of a typical sample
from the mean
well there's variation one in every
single coordinate so the squared errors
are going to sort of add up to D and
then we take the square root because
it's Euclidean distance so basically a
typical point is going to be distance
Square D away from the mean and so
without actually having points that look
necessarily weird at all from the
perspective of even the true probability
density you can skew the mean quite a
bit and so this is kind of this is
something that's been well understood
for a while now and there's been a lot
of recent work including by many people
in this room that designs outlier robust
estimators that actually do much better
than this naive square root of D
estimate in in a number of settings not
just mean estimation but regression
classification and other tests as well
but what I want to talk about and focus
on in in this talk is can we somehow
generalize these insights to other types
of corruptions that the data might have
because as we saw earlier outliers are
only one type of problem that you might
have and in the same way that in high
dimensions you run into problems with
outliers you also run into problems with
these other types of corruptions and so
in this talk I'm going to explain and
then try to generalize and extend the
insights from this
liar setting to to other types of
corruptions as well so we'll first sort
of talk about the outlier set in
particular just as parsley review and
partially to kind of unify some of the
ideas then we'll talk about some tools
for doing finite sample analysis it
actually turns out that when you care
about robustness your questions of how
much data you need are actually
surprisingly more complicated than if
you just want a regular estimator and
then then we'll talk about how to
generalize to other corruptions and the
class of corruptions we'll look at is
something called Wasserstein corruptions
which will contain all of the examples I
gave earlier so just to nail down the
formal setting here is a picture of kind
of traditional statistics or traditional
machine learning we have some population
distribution P which is what we want to
learn about but we don't ever get to
directly observe P instead we get
samples x1 through xn that are often
usually drawn iid from P we have some
estimated parameters theta hat and then
there's some cost function that tells us
sort of how well we did under these
parameters for instance in
classification this might be the zero
one loss or the cross-entropy loss so
this is kind of traditional statistical
estimation but if we want to talk about
robustness we're going to add in a
wrinkle which is that we never have
direct access to the true distribution
even via samples instead what happens is
this true distribution is first
corrupted via some process typically the
process is it gets replaced with some
arbitrary distribution which is in some
small ball around the original
distribution under some distance and
then we get samples from this corrupted
distribution but our cost is still with
respect to the original true
distribution so just to give some
examples one cost would so I guess an
entire family of examples would be what
I what I was referring to as Wall Street
in distances earlier
so this says we have some cost C of XY
to move a point X to a point y we're
allowed to apply any kind of
transformation where the average cost
over all of the points is bounded by
Epsilon
so one simple example would be if the
cost is just a delta function so one if
I move a point in 0 if I don't move a
point then saying that the average cost
has to be at most epsilon is saying that
I can move at most an epsilon fraction
of the points and so this is called the
total variational distance and this
would capture outliers where there's
some small fraction of the data that's
arbitrarily corrupted another cost might
just be the l2 distance so this is
saying we can move all of the points
around but the average amount I move
each point in l2 norm has to be bounded
again by some small Epsilon so this
corresponds to this measurement error
case from before where we might have
measured our covariance incorrectly you
could have more exotic things as well so
we could do the l0 norm which means that
some small fraction of the entries of
each data point are corrupted but this
is sort of the general setting that
we'll be thinking about yes yeah so x1
through xn are drawn iid from P tilde
draw from P and then you just corrupt an
epsilon fraction of them good question
so so this is not equivalent so right so
this is a good point so there's a
stronger model which is that this
corruption appears instead of appearing
here it sort of appears after the
samples so the corruption gets to pay
attention to the randomness so pretty
much everything I'm going to say is
going to hold under that model as well
the main reason I'm not writing it down
is actually when you move from from this
like outlier case to more general
corruptions it becomes a little bit
tricky how to actually define what it
means for the adversary to be allowed to
be
adaptive so there's some like slight
definitional definitional issues that
you can you can like resolve but I
didn't want to sort of go into those in
detail yeah this is this is a good
question though they could have
completely disjoint supports and still
be like closing over distance or
something yeah so for right so this is
like the the reason we want these sorts
of distances as opposed to say something
like Cale distance is you want to allow
for things that would have disjoint
support since at least I believe that
this often is going to be true in
practice any other questions on the
setting
and I'll say yeah I feel free to
interrupt with questions at any point
one other point here is like the other
important aspect here is we need to make
some sort of assumptions or else we're
going to be completely hosed because if
I don't assume anything about what the
real distribution looks like then
there's nothing ruling out that P tilde
is the real distribution and so there or
like whatever the like weirdest thing
and the ball around P tilde is so we
need to sort of say something like that
the real distribution has some sort of
nice properties in order to actually
have any hope of of doing recovery and
because we're going to have to make
assumptions and are basically
fundamentally going to have to lean on
these assumptions now it becomes
important to think carefully about what
these assumptions are because we want to
make ones that are that are actually
reasonable that we're willing to believe
in because this isn't just some like
analysis convenience that's allowing us
to sort of like see what's going on it's
actually a fundamental part of the
problem statement so there's going to be
three goals here the first is we want
these assumptions to be as weak as
possible while still being able to do
something so we want usually we encode
the assumptions by saying that the true
distribution lies within some family so
we want this family to be as large as
possible
but we also want it to be the case that
we can actually get small error so I
usually refer to this as the population
limit the limit of how small you can
make the air if you say had infinitely
many samples then the final thing we're
going to care about is the statistical
rate so we want the dependence on n
before we get to small error to be not
too bad so these are the three things
that are going to care about and in some
sense the issue before was that at least
if you sort of make theta hat to be this
naive algorithm that just discards
points that are too far away even the
population limit will be quite bad it'll
have this root D factor yes
you don't care about computational cost
of data hunt great so in this talk I'm
actually only going to be worried about
the statistical properties there are
some pretty interesting computational
questions that I think are rise that are
basically all open so hopefully someone
in this room will solve them and then we
can all write some nice papers okay so
let's like so that was quite abstract
let's let's try to be a bit more
concrete so here's a simple problem was
just returned to this mean estimation
example from before just sort of try to
understand what might go on
so here the distance is going to be
total variational distance which is
modeling these outliers and our loss is
we're going to output some parameter
theta and our our loss function is just
going to be the error between theta and
the true mean of our distribution P
under some norm so here here's um
there's this result that actually it
goes back quite a while so I think this
was first observed by Donahoe and Lu
that tells you sort of exactly what the
answer is in this case as a function of
your family G so the the result is the
following it says let's suppose that the
true distribution lies within some
family G and define the following
estimator theta hat so theta hat will be
the mean of a distribution Q where Q is
the closest distribution to G in total
variational distance so basically I'm
I'm going to like take some distribution
that I'm given so this will be my just
the corrupted distribution P tilde if it
all already satisfies whatever
assumptions I was making in terms of the
family G then I'm just going to output
the mean of P tilde itself if it doesn't
then I'm going to find the closest thing
to G or sorry the closest thing in G to
P tilde I'm going to output the mean of
that and so first of all this is basic
this well it's not basically this is
often well up to a factor of two you can
prove that and also the loss that you
get is upper bounded by this quantity
that we call the modulus of continuity
of G which is the maximum over all pairs
of distributions in G that are close
together in total variational distance
of their difference in mean so this is
saying that if any if my assumptions are
such that anytime I have two
distributions that both satisfy those
assumptions that are close together in
total variational distance they'll also
be close and mean that I'm okay and
conversely if I don't have this
assumption that I'm actually always
going to be hosed because I could have
just take the worst case here and make
this guy P star and this guy P tilde and
they're close in TV distance so I can
always corrupt one to the other and I'm
so I'm not going to ever be able to do
better though so this is saying that
this projection algorithm is basically
optimal and the proof of why you get
this bound is just the following so we
know that if P is close to P star say
total variational distance at most
epsilon then Q is close to P and
therefore are also close to P star so Q
and P star have total variational
distant most to epsilon invite
construction they both lie in Gees so
this is why you get this so again this
is a little bit abstract so let's see
what this means in some special cases so
let's just suppose our family G with
gaussians so we're assuming that the
true distribution is Gaussian and we
want to estimate its mean sort of this
requires some algebra but what you can
show is that the total variational
distance between two gaussians is
roughly equal to the l2 distance between
their means and so this means that the
modulus here is going to be proportional
to epsilon so this is
saying if I want to estimate the mean of
Gaussian in the presence of outliers I
can actually get error epsilon and this
is note that the trivial algorithm was
epsilon root D so this is doing much
much better than what you would get
naively and well okay computationally
it's not clear you can do this but at
least as a proof of concept algorithm
this is like a two line algorithm so so
this is kind of nice and it turned out
that you didn't really need it to be
Gaussian so Gaussian is particularly
nice because you can do the computation
exactly but even if you're subbed out
soon you can actually show that this
modulus is also small so it's no longer
Epsilon
but it's epsilon times a square root log
directly and in general sort of the key
property is whenever you have something
within tails you can show that the
modulus is going to be small just Co
sort of epsilon perturbations of a thin
tail distribution can't really change
the mean that much and we'll formalize
this property on the next slide using a
concept called resilience are there any
questions before I move on the good
question so if going back to this idea
about how we made this diagram of crept
anticipation and sampling or sampling
then corrupt so if we sampled and
corrupt then so because you've thrown
out computation it's fine to be doing
everything in distribution space in it
if we instantiate these algorithms or
the finite corrupted sample are there
any interesting because you said
everything kind of goes through but so
right so I there's another issue with
this algorithm which is that it's
completely nonsensical and finite
samples because the total variational
distance between a distribution and
samples from that distribution is one
which is the maximum possible total
variational distance so yeah so this is
a very good point and I will in I think
two slides tell you how you can do
almost exactly the same algorithm and
finite
samples and have it actually work
you you Nate well so the the basic idea
is you need to replace total variational
distance with a different distance but
it's not the watch adjusting distance is
a different yeah so but no this is this
is a good catch so right so this is this
is doesn't work in finite samples at all
and I'll tell you how to do it okay
first I want to sort of generalize this
claim about sub joseon's so this is
based on a definition called resilience
and we'll say a distribution is
resilient with parameters Rho and
epsilon if the distance between the mean
of P and the mean of our is that most
Rho whenever R is less than or equal to
P over 1 minus Epsilon
this is sort of a weird algebraic
identity but what this means is that our
can be obtained from P by conditioning
on some event of probability 1 minus
Epsilon so this is basically saying I
take my distribution P I chop off some
epsilon massive P then I take the mean
of the remaining mass and that should
never be able to change the mean around
very much so this will be true for sub
Gaussian x' it'll basically be true for
anything within tails and you can think
of this as sort of a formalization of
saying that the distribution should have
like thin epsilon tails so the lemma is
that let's take G to actually just be
all distributions satisfying this
property so all grow Epsilon resilient
distributions then the modulus of this
family resilient distributions is at
most two Rho and the proof is is kind of
cute
so the proof is let's suppose I have two
distributions that are both resilient so
let's say one is this blue guy and one
is this green guy and let's also suppose
that these distributions are close in
total variational distance so then what
I'm going to do is I'm going to define a
midpoint distribution which is just the
point wise minimum of their densities if
they don't have densities you can
actually still make this kosher but
let's just think of them as having
densities for now so that would be this
red distribution here and the thing to
observe is that if I have two
distributions that are close in total
variational distance if I do this min
operation and then I renormalize the
constant I have to renormalize by is
always at least 1 minus Epsilon so so
this distribution will can be thought of
as basically the amount that I'm staring
out is is actually at most epsilon for
both the blue and green distributions so
this red distribution can be thought of
as this 1 minus epsilon probability of
event with respect to either
distribution and so if we think about
its mean well its mean has to be close
to the mean of the blue guy because the
blue guy is resilient and it has to be
close to the mean of the green guy
because the green guy is New Zealand and
so if I triangle inequality the blue and
green guys have to be close so this is
why this is why this is enough to give
you bounded modulus and the more
important thing is that actually this
this bound on the modulus is in pretty
much like all known cases going to give
you the optimal bound so basically for
like all families where we know how to
do robust estimation it actually turns
out that if you just say what is the
smallest like row and epsilon for which
that family is contained in the
resilient distributions and then I just
apply that bound that gives you a tight
analysis so this is this is in some
sense all you need to be thinking about
you just need to be asking what happens
if I chop off the tails of my
distribution so the next thing I want to
do is answer my teachers question about
finite samples so in some sense this
resilience characterization tells us
exactly what we need an infinite samples
but the algorithm is
no good because it relies on total
variational distance so what are right
so this algorithm that's just doing the
sort of projection under TV distance is
no good in finite samples so what should
we be doing instead so the solution is
we're just going to relax total
variational distance to more forgiving
distance what's the more forgiving
distance going to be I'm going to take
some family of functions H and I'm going
to and these are going to be functions
that map my space to the real line I'm
going to take the supreme overall
thresholds T and all functions in my
family of the probability that H of X is
bigger than T under P minus the
probability that H of X is bigger than T
under Q why should we think of this as
being related to the total variational
distance well the total variational
distance is the maximum over all events
e of the probability of e under P minus
the probability of e under Q so if I
took a supremum over all functions
instead of just all functions in H
though this would be exactly the total
variational distance and so this is
saying I'm going to only look at some
functions and so the key is I need to
look at enough functions that this
distance is still meaningful but not so
many functions that I can't get good
finite sample concentration so there's
two lemmas that you need to prove to get
this the first is that if we take H to
be all linear functionals of say we're
an Rd we take H to be all linear
functionals on Rd then the modulus of
continuity with respect to this distance
is still going to be small for the for
the family of resilient distributions
and therefore in all of the cases that
that we know about so it suffice is
basically to take this as our H and then
the second lemma is that and this is
actually a classical result I got in
trouble for this citation last time I
give this talk so apparently DeVry
Lugo's
wrote it up in their textbook but it was
known long before that and I actually
don't know who originally pointed this
out but it turns out that this distance
the distance between P and its empirical
distribution goes down as the square
root of the VC dimension of H divided by
n so this is going to give you a do-over
and rate in this case and even if you
needed some other family as long as this
family has bounded VC dimension you're
going to be okay so these are the two
things you need in order to make the
finite sample story work again this
algorithm so now this algorithm works in
finite samples it's still no good
computationally although it turns out
that this is very similar to the two key
median as an estimator I don't know if
you want to think of that as good or bad
because the two key median is np-hard to
compute but it's at least like an
estimator that's been around for a while
so this isn't something that I sort of
completely pulled out of nowhere
it should be the VC dimension yeah yeah
yeah so let's see we need to turn this
into our processes class somehow you do
you do this thing yeah okay so I should
this should be vapnik contributing
because they do they have they have a I
haven't actually I am very simply
haven't read that the original you see
favors oh yeah this is this one
combinatoric you're citing here okay
well apparently those references now I
really get in trouble for this reference
okay I should have just left it out and
then yeah yeah since there are so many
references this is an entire book on
Soylent I can believe there are the
reference distance this kind of looks
like the original flamenco cante la
stuff if any of these old references did
you find discussion of robust statistics
so not in those references although I
admit I haven't like religiously checked
everything this is related so this
construction is sort of somewhat similar
to another construction called a
skeleton estimator which has gotten used
both in the robust statistics world in
the regular world there though generally
what's happening is you can show that
the like optimal supper basically if you
can show that the optimal separating
event all must always lie within some
low dimensional family then like for
instance for gaussians if I'm looking at
the total variation all this
between two gaussians the optimal
suffering if that actually is always a
half space and so like if my family was
gaussians this would actually be exact
and so this is this is sort of an
argument that is often made but here
actually it turns out this is an
actually relaxation so the optimal event
doesn't have to be a half space but you
can show that it's sort of close enough
to a half space later okay I think this
is like the closest connection that I've
seen but I I could have like I wouldn't
be like completely shocked if if I'd
miss something it's not yes it's not
necessary so here's a way to see this
let's suppose that my family was either
gaussians with a mean that was at least
ten and variance one or so I'm like very
heavy tailed distribution where I know
the mean must be zero so then this isn't
resilient because this very heavy tailed
distribution is not not going to be
resilient because of the heavy tails but
since like I have an estimator that will
do well I'm just going to like see if it
looks approximately Gaussian and if it
does that I'm going to do my robust
estimator for gaussians and otherwise
I'm just going to output zero this is a
very silly estimator right like but it
does show that you like there exist
cases that are not resilient where you
can do something we have so like Banco
and jad Tao and I have a conjecture that
any reasonable distribution where you
can do stuff is going to be resilient
but it's a bit challenging to formalize
what reasonable should mean
so computationally what is this approach
look like we have to do a minimization
of this max over linear yeah so you're
going to take the min overall well this
is for computing the distance R for
doing the projection yeah so you're
going to take the min overall cue that
are resilient which itself is I guess
checking resilience is tricky although
perhaps like a sufficient condition for
resilience is bounded covariance so you
can take the min over all bounded
covariance distributions which you might
be a bit happier with because that's
something we can actually search over
efficiently in many cases of the max
over all T and H of of this probability
and
well it was they're going to say yeah
that I guess that would this would be
the algorithm so it's going to be I
guess basically exponential time at
least it's not doubly exponential but
yeah it's going to basically be a min
max problem
okay I want to move on to examples other
than mean estimation because I mean
making you stare at this one problem for
the last half hour so let's briefly go
over the rest of the TV case and then
we'll go on to watch 15 corruptions like
I promised so for 4 V I mean estimation
ok we'll still talk about TV distance
but this Erin mean will get replaced
with some arbitrary laws L of P theta it
turns out the modulus of continuity
still gives you an upper bound it's no
longer provably optimal in fact it's not
like you can construct counter examples
where it's not optimal but it still
gives a pretty tight analysis in most
cases so how are we going to generalize
this modulus so before we were going to
like take our distribution our corrupted
distribution projected on to the family
G and then output the mean now instead
of outputting the mean we're just going
to output theta star of that
distribution so the Alpha the parameters
that would be optimal if we assume that
was the true distribution and then
you're still going to be upper bounded
by this modulus right now instead of
distance in means it's going to be the
error that you would that you obtained
under P if you guess the optimal
parameter under P Prime
and you can generalize the idea of
resilience to the setting so before
resilience meant that you were close and
mean whenever you did this epsilon
deletion now you're actually going to
need two conditions because like
difference in mean is symmetric but this
loss is asymmetric so the first
condition says that if we if we predict
with P but the true distribution was an
epsilon deletion of P then we're going
to do well and so this is sort of saying
you can go downwards if I'm sort of
assuming that I'm doing that I take that
if I take the optimal parameters under P
I'm going to do well on all 1 minus
epsilon subsets of P
and the other one is letting us go up it
says if I find something that does well
on a 1 minus epsilon subset then I'm
going to do well under P so this just
lets you do both directions and you can
prove that in this case the modulus will
still be bounded basically because I'm
gonna still bounce I can still form a
midpoint if I have any distribution P
and P Prime I can do this min operation
to create a midpoint and then if I guess
that P prime is right but I'm going to
do well under our under the midpoint and
therefore I'm going to do well under P
so if that was too fast that I wouldn't
worry too much about the details but
this is just to show you can generalize
this idea so let's see what this
actually gives in some concrete cases
other than mean estimation so maybe the
simplest case up after me an estimation
would be regression so we're doing
linear regression where we have samples
XY drawn from some distribution P our
error is the squared error and actually
it's we'll want to do a squared error
relative to the best squared error we
could get so that we don't end up with
like this random extra term from the
from the variance of the noise so this
is sort of the excess predictive loss
for linear regression so here's where we
can say in linear regression so remember
for mean estimation the condition we
needed was basically bounded tails so
something like some Gaussian are bounded
caithe moments or something like that
here it's going to be kind of similar
but we need to be careful about what
tails are bounded and how they're
bounded since we have both x and y so
first let's define Z to be the noise
so Y minus theta star transpose X where
theta star is the true parameters or the
optimal parameters under P under the
true distribution the things that we
need are we need Z to have thin tails so
say the two Cates moments of Z are
bounded and we need X to have thin tails
in every direction
but how we're going to measure the tails
well we're going to measure them
relative to the covariance matrix of X
so we need the two caithe moments of V
transpose X for every V to be at most
some constant times the K power of the
second moment so this should be for some
K bigger than two so these are the two
conditions we need and maybe to like see
why you would care about how big the
tails are relative to the covariance
well suppose you had something that
suppose your design like suppose your
covariance were very thin along some
dimension then you'd kind of this is
like kind of bad from the perspective of
robust estimation because it means
you're very close to singular and maybe
like a small number of deletions could
actually make you actually become
singular and so you need if you're very
thin along some direction you actually
need very good concentration along that
direction to make sure that
perturbations of your distribution can't
can't push you down to being singular so
this is why this is sort of the right
thing to normalize by the axis of
Gaussian random vector if it K were well
yeah you only need to hold for one K so
sub Gaussian would be if this sort of
held for K approximately logarithmic lee
large
oh so the guarantee I get is going to
depend on what ki I have so here I'm
going to get a bound that goes as
epsilon to the two minus two over K
where epsilon is the fraction of
outliers so the the point is that okay
my took K to be like log 1 over epsilon
then then this would go away and then I
would get sort of the sub Gaussian some
Gaussian rate but even if you're not
subbed out seein like you have just
bounded forth moments if we took K to be
2 and we'll still get something
meaningful but yes it you you can think
of it as like sub Gaussian or bounded
moments so Gaussian would certainly
suffice as long as the way you measure
sub Gaussian is in the like with respect
to the covariance matrix just to sort of
also deuce so I guess I want to compare
this to some existing results these are
computationally efficient results so
this is uh this is why the bounds are
looser yep
ten minutes you said four or five okay
so these bounds are looser but are
computationally efficient but basically
maybe a very tempting algorithm would be
to just like if you're given a bunch of
points delete the points that like
delete the points such that you can make
their aggression error on the remaining
points as small as possible
so basically solve this joint
minimization problem over basically find
the epsilon points to delete and find
the parameters which the resulting
squared error is minimized that's not
efficient but climene's Kothari and
mekka show how to use sum of squares to
efficiently do this but it actually
turns out this algorithm gets the gets a
suboptimal error even though it's a very
tempting algorithm so it gets this an
area that's the square root of this area
so epsilon to the 1 minus 1 over K
instead of epsilon to the 2 minus 2 over
K so actually this projection estimator
is doing something fairly non-trivial
that's that's better than just what you
would sort of do maybe straightforwardly
and then there's also a result that does
get the right rate but under more
specific assumptions basically some
stronger moment assumptions so I think
this information theoretic picture can
actually be useful because it tends to
give you like very simple statements of
exactly what you need and then we can
worry about how to do something
efficiently so I think an interesting
open problem even in this case is can we
get something that's achieving this rate
under under sort of under assumptions
that look like this rather than that
look like this okay there's also results
for covariance estimation I think since
I'm running low on time I want to to
skip this and go on to Wall Street in
perturbations so in the total
variational case we had that this
modulus determined robustness and then
resilience gave us this sufficient
condition for robustness we're going to
extend this to wall stretching distances
what's a Wall Street in distance it's
this family of distances I defined at
the beginning so basically where I have
some cost to move a point X to a point Y
and then the wall starting distance
between P and Q is the cost to move the
distribution P to the dissociation Q
where I'm sort of basically where I'm
like paying a cost to move each
individual points so I'm trying to find
kind of the optimal way to align points
in P to points and Q under this cost
function there's a way to formalize this
in terms of optimal couple lanes which I
won't sort of go into here but again
just think of this as I'm trying to sort
of move the density from one place to
another and everything I discussed just
now there's kind of this key property
that's very tied to total variational
distance which was this midpoint
property so I kept using the fact that
if I have two distributions that are
close together in total variational
distance then I can take the min of
their two densities and I get this
distribution that's a deletion of both
of them that sort of a midpoint of both
distributions but also kind of nicely
controlled in that it it's
only has deletions right you could think
of that equivalently as as a lemma
that's saying okay total variational
distance says I'm allowed to delete some
points and then add some other points
but I can decompose that into just
deleting points and deleting points and
since deletions are much easier to deal
with than additions this makes my life a
lot easier but if instead of having
outliers I'm just moving all of my
points around it's a lot less clear how
to do this decomposition captured under
the worsens team metric with discrete
cost function or something yes so I
guess what I'm so yes so the total
variation Liston's is a Wasserstein
distance I guess what I'm saying is that
in some sense it's a very special type
of Wasserstein distance
where we kind of can decompose
everything into these two pieces and
actually we'll see that that property
isn't as special as it looked like we
can actually generalize this idea but it
at least requires some some thought how
we're going to generalize this to other
types of but yes you you're right that
that TV is uh okay so I just want to
show you a picture that's going to kind
of help us see how to do this
generalization so let's just think about
one-dimensional distributions so so
remember resilience was about what
happens if I delete some epsilon mass
how much can I move the mean an
equivalent operation would be instead of
deleting this epsilon mass I'm actually
going to move it all to the mean of the
new distribution so not to the mean of
the original distribution but to the
mean of the distribution I end up at so
it's a it's a circular definition but
the thing that is helpful here is that
when I think in this perspective well
first of all if I change the if I change
my definition to this it doesn't change
the answer at all right because moving
all of the mass to the mean of the
target distribution isn't going to
change the mean of the target
distribution
so it's just the same as if I had
deleted it from the respective of how
far I can move things but now that I'm
talking about movement instead of
deletion well movement is something that
makes sense for any Walter same distance
because Walter sees distances are
exactly about moving things around and
so this is sort of the perspective
that's going to let us generalize this
midpoint level so it motivates the
following definition which we call a
friendly perturbation so we'll say for a
distribution P over some space X first
let's let's fix a function f from X to
the real line this is just because the
picture I just drew was in one dimension
so we want a nice one-dimensional thing
to be going on we'll say a distribution
R is an epsilon friendly perturbation of
P if there is a way to couple the points
in P and R such that the following two
things are true first the average costs
under that couple in is at most Epsilon
and also all points move towards the
mean of our so f of y is between f of X
in the expectation of f of X almost
surely so this is this is just sort of
formalizing this picture it's saying
we're allowing all perturbations that
move things towards the mean except that
I'm allowing more than just moving it
exactly to the mean I'm also allowed to
sort of like stop halfway if I want so
the total variation whole case this this
again wouldn't change the answer and
then we actually have the same midpoint
limit as before instead of proving it
formally here's just a proof by picture
let's suppose I had a distribution P the
distribution P Prime and I want to show
that there's some midpoint distribution
what am I going to do I'm going to guess
what the mean of the midpoint
distribution should be and then by
assumption I can move stuff from P to P
Prime with small average cost so instead
what I'm going to do is I'm going to try
to move stuff from P to P Prime when I
hit the mean of our I'm just going to
stop and not move further and then I can
do the symmetric thing here and so now
I've moved sort of both things to this
single midpoint distribution and then
you just need to prove a fixed point
theorem that shows
that you can actually pick Ameen such
that like this was guessing the mean and
then I'm gonna get a distribution whose
mean might not be that mean but you need
you can through a fixed-point theorem
that you can actually find a guess that
works and so this kind of comes down to
saying if X has nice topology then then
we have this middle point result you can
sort of generalize everything from the
total variational case I'm not going to
sort of go into it in detail but maybe
the one wrinkle is like I've done this
all for some one-dimensional function f
how do we extend to an arbitrary loss
you can't do it always but you can do it
for a very large family of distances
anything that's convex in P which is a
very weak condition for instance neural
nets are convex in P like in the
distribution even though they're not
convex in theta and this is by using the
central Moro theorem so anything that's
convex in P has some representation as a
supreme over one dimensional functions
and so you can apply this sort of
friendly perturbation notion to each 1
dimensional function and then you get
you get some sort of band so if you sort
of push this all through you can for
instance under earthmover distance get
similar results the total variational
case but where the moment bounds are
slightly different so instead of needing
like two caithe moments you're going to
need two K plus two moments to get the
same sorts of results and you can show
that this is actually sort of what you
should expect there's again an
interesting both an interesting
statistical question and an interesting
computational question so statistically
we are getting two minus two over K
before and now we're getting one minus 1
over K this is due to some sort of
subtle technical issues the interesting
computational question is like in the TV
case I was comparing to a bunch of
computational algorithms that were
efficient but needed stronger
assumptions than the ones I wrote down
in this case say under L like
Wasserstein l2 corruptions there are no
efficient algorithms to compare to like
just as far as I know no one has
designed robust estimators in this
so just like doing anything there it
would be interested in and then I
haven't talked at all about the finite
sample analysis but also the finite
sample analysis is a lot harder in this
case and we're pretty sure we don't have
anywhere close to the optimal bounds
mainly like there's this like really
obnoxious 1 over N to the one third term
shouldn't be there but we can't be like
we spent a while and we couldn't make it
go away so I won't get into this in the
talk because it would take way too long
but I'd be happy to talk about this
offline with anyone who wants to so I
will end there
[Applause]
what the coefficients are describing
so I think well I guess it depends on
whether you think Wasserstein distances
are geometric like some some people
would say yes and some people would say
no I mean generally what you're doing is
you're kind of you have some notion of
niceness which is like this resilience
notion although probably in any
computational setting you need to
replace that with something that's
easier to work with and then you're
trying to sort of like slide all of your
points around under this washer steam
distance to move towards a nicer
distribution so generally like the
efficient algorithms you get actually
can be interpreted as some optimization
algorithm that balances two terms one is
like so basically it's an optimization
algorithm where you start with some
points like some points x1 through xn
and have new points y1 through yn and
your two terms are like you sort of want
Y to be close to X but you also want the
Y's to be nice and so usually when you
can get something efficient it's because
you can come up with convex surrogates
for those two notions so that's maybe I
know if that's geometric maybe that's
like one good way to think about this
any quick thoughts on the finite sample
analysis or but that's you know coming
up with at the top and I was
one of the distance you have any
thoughts on that so yeah so the base
right so I guess the thing that we've
tried which is what currently has this
like n to the minus one-third is you
just sort of generalize this like TV
tilde estimator to sort of like washer
Steen tilde estimator the problem is
like in TV tilde things are nice because
you just care about probabilities so
like probabilities are going to always
kind of concentrate on a 1 over root n
rate because of Chernoff bounds here
like if you care about washers same
distance you kind of want to say I have
this distribution that can potentially
be quite heavy tailed and I want samples
from that distribution to be like close
to the original distribution and washers
change distance now I need to control
like the average l2 movement of how much
things need to move around and basically
the problem is just like this could have
very heavy tails and it's hard to
concentrate so I think like that control
of the l2 movement yeah so this is this
is somehow the difficulty is that
because l2 distance could be unbounded
unlike unlike total variational like
unlike just this like Delta function
distance basically at the unboundedness
of the l2 norm is what makes everything
really hard so is somehow like we had to
find matrix concentration inequalities
that work for unbounded distributions
but then those were like not like too
loose and yeah this is
okay so let's think a key
[Applause]